[Music]
the nature moments and movement of this
knowing have then shown themselves to be
such that this knowing is a pure being
for self of self-consciousness it is I
that is this and no other eye and which
is no less immediately a mediated or
superseded Universal eye
it has a Content which it differentiates
from itself for it is pure negativity or
the dividing of itself it is
consciousness
this content is in its difference itself
the eye for it is the movement of
superseding itself or the same pure
negativity that the eye is in it as
differentiated the I is reflected into
itself it is only when the eye communes
with itself in its otherness that the
content is comprehended that is in terms
of the notion
stated more specifically this content is
nothing else than the very movement just
spoken of for the content is spirit that
traverses its own self and does so for
itself as Spirit by the fact that it has
the shape of the notion in its
objectivity
paragraph
799 is the third in this sequence of
four short paragraphs that are
transitioning us Across the Threshold
not only numerically into the 800s as
far as the numeration of the paragraphs
go and and once we get there we've only
got eight more paragraphs to cross
before we finish up with the
phenomenology but there's also an
important transition taking place as we
move across that
first Finish Line into the 800s as
you're going to see in the next
paragraph here we're kind of wrapping up
with this discussion of the shape of
Consciousness that absolute knowing this
section this not just section but what
is being represented or better put
conceptualized right thought out
conceptually by the phenomenologist by
Hegel by us the readers
in this which is the shape that we
ourselves are taking on as what do you
want to call us
Tagalongs emissaries participants in
spirit so that's what's going on with
this and you notice at the end of this
paragraph We have the shape right the
Gestalt of what the notion or the
concept the Beth in its objectivity it's
so that's what absolute knowing is
really going to be about or at least
part of it
and what we see here is a really
concentrated discussion of what it is at
this point to be an i or an ego if you
if you prefer an e right in hegel's
German so he starts this in a very
dramatic way the nature moments and
movement of this knowing right so this
is a rather summery right the nature
what the thing is of this knowing the
moments all the different parts of it
that are Incorporated and the
directionality the movement the
orientation of this knowing this Vision
have then shown themselves to be such
that what this knowing
is a and here we get something that has
been said before pure
being for South physic Zine right first
exyne nothing really radically new there
of
self-consciousness
now the idea that self-consciousness is
being for itself again we encountered
that all the way back in the
self-consciousness section but we
shouldn't
forget that as the hegelian dialectic
goes along we're not just replicating
reproducing what it is that we saw
before that's why you know people
there's a bit of a side note here or an
aside people who will say oh yeah Hegel
I know that guy Master Slave dialectic
you can see it everywhere Hegel would be
looking at those people and saying you
don't get it do you
we get Beyond The Master Slave dialectic
as a matter of fact we don't just get
Beyond it I mean it does replicate
itself in the present in certain
Dynamics but as a overarching culture
civilization whatever you want to call
us that human beings have become over
the centuries we left that rudimentary
stuff behind long ago right and we get
to more and more complicated matters
right complicated shapes
so what is this pure being for self a
self-consciousness
it is I now here's where he's he's going
to set out two different interesting
signs
so it is I right and when we say that
we're saying that well Hegel is saying
he is an I right he is the one
who sees uh this this development this
dialectic that has taken place and now
can call it absolute knowing but we too
you as an i me is an i and there's two
really important sides of this so
there's a side of particularity or even
individuality
uh he doesn't use those terms there
instead he says this and no other I
right so this eye the eye that I am and
no other eye not that I over there not
the I that you happen to be but at the
same time this I is also now here is
he's maybe even like playing with words
no less immediately right
a mediated
fermented and superseded alcohol
business
Universal I
so this is the case
for all of us at a certain point in
development right so long as we have a
stake in this vast process of well what
Spirit what is the point of all is what
is the essential what is the vasant leak
right what do I actually know we are
part of this mediated and superseded
Universal eye
we're not just this eye the particular
eye that we are and both of these are
equally I when we say that
it's encapsulated in both at least at
this stage of the dialectic
so now he's going to talk about content
in halt
and he's gonna there's an interesting
play with words here right so it
differentiates it's dividing it's
differentiated all of these are using uh
winter Shaden or unter shed and right or
unter shiden there's a verb and a noun
that are playing a role there we could
also say dividing splitting into Parts
he's actually going to use some other
vocabulary along with that so he says it
has it has a Content he doesn't say it
is a Content it has a content right
which it differentiates from itself
so then he goes on he says uh for it is
pure negativity well what's the yeah
it's the I the I is pure negativity
we've seen this already that's part of
self-consciousness
that's part of Consciousness as such
even consciousness of the object that
we're taking in in sense certainty
Consciousness is more it is a negativity
that doesn't fit into what the content
itself
is and so it it's engaging in this
differentiating it from itself uh the
dividing of itself right so another uh
you know
term there that's similar it is
consciousness the content is in its
difference all of these are the same
thing just expressed as nouns and verbs
dividing splitting apart but maintaining
connection between them not dividing is
like you go over there and I'm
forgetting about you you go over there
I'll pay attention to you they're both
part of the process
so what happens with this dividing
this superseding itself
Haven right this is the auf Haven of the
eye Itself by the eye
within itself
so he goes on and he says
um the pure negativity that the eye is
in it as differentiated
the I is reflected into itself in the
reflect yet right is just a cognet right
there so what does that mean it is only
when the eye communes with itself now
communes is kind of a big term Hegel
doesn't actually use that it's just with
itself when the eye is with itself so
commuting is is fine but you know it
doesn't imply this like uh
very new agey kind of sounding thing it
communes with itself in its otherness in
its being other that the content is
comprehended
so you know be Griffin it is grasped
conceptually no longer just as we had in
religion through representation or
through some sort of participation in a
community it is actually grasping it is
comprehending itself in its totality
here as an eye as the end of
history if we want to look ahead a
little bit right
and so he he's going to say now he has
in terms of the notion and brackets and
that's right right this is in terms of
the concept
so now he says stated more specifically
so if we want to rephrase this
what's going on the content is nothing
else then the very movement just spoken
of now which movement I think we can see
two references here
what is the movement of differentiating
and thereby superseding or sublating
that's part of it but you know how did
we actually begin this paragraph the
nature moments and movements of this
knowing that's I think that's another
reference there so
the very movement just spoken of for the
content the in-house
the the content that the eye has
nothing else
the uh the content is spirit that
traverses its own self
and does so for itself once again we go
to the being for itself right as spirit
by the fact that it has now here's where
we began it has the shape the Gestalt
the Gestalt of absolute knowing right
the shape of the notion the shape of the
concept the grief in its objectivity its
gagan Stanley kite is something that can
be put out against ourselves that's why
it has to differentiate right because
without the differentiation you can't
actually look at it and wrap your head
around it another way we could talk
about uh
as the eye that you are grasping
what
and what of and where you're going right
that's the nature and moments and
movement that we started with all of
that is sort of encapsulated in this and
Hagel is unpacking it for us here in
this short little paragraph
but as regards the existence of this
notion science does not appear in time
and in the actual world before Spirit
has attained to this Consciousness about
itself as spirit that knows what it is
it does not exist before and nowhere at
all till after the completion of its
work of compelling its imperfect shape
to procure for its Consciousness the
shape of its Essence and in this way to
equate its self-consciousness with its
consciousness
spirit that is in and for itself and
differentiated into its moments is a
knowing that is for itself a
comprehension in general that as such
substance has not yet reached that his
substance is not in its own self and
absolute knowing
paragraph 800 brings to a close this
sequence of four short but very
important transitional
sections or passages
within this last section of the
phenomenology and you notice Hegel here
he's already used the term visionsoft or
science just a few paragraphs before but
now it's going to take on a greater role
and we're saying something really
interesting about it in relation to time
zeit which we're going to be looking at
in the paragraphs yet to come and we'll
hold off on that for just a second
there's a lot to say about that but also
in actuality vehicle kite and before we
talk about the time thing let's talk
about actuality
I've mentioned this many times within
this commentary on the phenomenology and
I think that people sometimes lose sight
of this that Hegel is continually trying
to steer us back to
actuality if we don't
exist or our ideas or concepts don't
exist and do something in the real world
then the idealism that Hegel is engaged
in becomes
sterile and this is some you know
sometimes critiques that he'll make of
other thinkers right your idealism just
winds up being this you know night in
which all cows are black for example we
want real life
we want an idealism that isn't just us
being stuck in our heads or writing cool
things down on paper and sitting around
the coffee shop and chatting about them
we want real stuff and so visenshaft
science science in the very broad sense
better somehow translate into that and
not just become something as we often
joke about in the Ivory Tower right now
in time it's not just time that we're
talking about here
when you see him talking about time
think of something that makes it
distinctively human time history
the time that is Meaningful not just
time passing willy-nilly as in you know
numbers that we could count up or
something but time that matters time in
which things have developed another key
idea that we're going to be talking
about here
um imperfect Perfection
really more development unfolding uh
things becoming what they ought to be so
he goes on and he says as regards the
existence the design again very clear
cut right being there being actual of
this notion of this
what notion the shape of the notion in
its objectivity that we just referred to
in the previous
paragraph right the gestalts
the existence of this notion he said
science does not appear in time and in
the actual world
before
something important happens and it's
been happening throughout the entire
phenomenology
before Spirit has attained to this
Consciousness about itself now Spirit
has been engaging in this it had some
Consciousness about itself even before
we reach the spirit section in
Consciousness in self-consciousness and
then you know it's transformations in
reason in the spirit section in religion
all of these are the ways in which this
thing that Hegel calls Spirit or Geist
is unfolding itself through US human
beings throughout our history Bit by Bit
by Bit this is the dialectic and this is
how it actually works and it's you know
it's a messy process which is only
partially encapsulated here in the
phenomenology or even if we want to
extend it to other Hegel works you know
like think about his lectures on various
topics where we see developmental stuff
going on or the you know philosophy of
right right thinking about political and
social math matters or the encyclopedia
logic or the science of logic all of
these are developmental
so he goes on and he says as spirit that
knows what it is that what it is again
referring back to the previous paragraph
the nature moments and movement of this
knowing that is Spirit knowing what it
is
this does not exist before and nowhere
near guns
nowhere at all till after the completion
of this work the full endung
the laboring the work that Spirit has
been doing this entire time and what has
it been doing it is going from its
imperfect we can say shape
gestaltunn which is not the same thing
as Gestalt right so think of this as
rudimentary unfoll comana right so we
have a you notice these four there those
two terms coming up folendum full comana
right the development the unfolding the
unpacking the
complexifying if you like so the
imperfect shape is one that is not yet
brought to its fruition it it's partly
there right it's not nothing but it's
not what it needs to be and we would be
mistaken to stop and say ah the essence
of hegel's Doctrine is what happened in
the Master Slave dialectic or forcing
the understanding or you know the
freedom and the terror pick whatever
other thing you want those are all
imperfect shapes and they are being
compelled but zvingen is a term he used
here through this completion of the work
that's compelling them into what
into the shape
of its Essence the Gestalt now
zionisms it's uh most essential thing
right compelling its imperfect shape and
so translated here to procure for its
Consciousness the shape of its Essence
not procure here
might not really be the best term
fairchoffen is the term that that Hegel
uses shafen is to shape to mold to
create to bring into being right and uh
the fair here you know sort of an
intensifier I would say in this case
um
the shape of its Essence is being
developed by spirit
through history through this process and
it is shaping itself
it doesn't have an external shaper and
and here a little bit of a digression
think back to the religion section right
why did we you know we had all this cool
stuff happening through reason and
spirit the two biggest sections of the
work uh no you know the gods did enter
in there or the Divine but it's mostly
you know human Affairs and we get this
you know you could even say more and
more secularizing or at least turning
the Divine into something human a human
humanistically uh uh
understanding picture of social reality
the reality that we live in the reality
that Spirit inhabits and shapes then we
go into this religion section why why do
we do that well you know by the end of
the religion section we actually have a
pretty humanistic form of Christianity
that you know foyerbach will pick up and
run with uh to to be sure but Hegel also
wants to tell us that it's not
a Creator from up on high
you know totally Transcendent to the
world and also mysteriously imminent to
it that like creates
uh the world that engage in shaffen
right it's Spirit itself which we're
part of
which we can understand we can not only
understand
uh but comprehend
we can grasp it with Concepts as us
being part of that
so you know okay digression over uh back
to this
now Hegel says something else that's
very interesting here
um over and over and over again in the
phenomenology he's been talking about
Consciousness and self-consciousness
right how do we bring the two of them
together right and
um sometimes it's Consciousness is in
itself or of the in itself and then
self-consciousness is for itself we're
going to see all that come together here
but what's happening in this process of
moving to the shape of the essence the
completion of the work
is that self-consciousness and
Consciousness are equated now the term
there
austu glycan right ausk glycan
is the term
um glycan as I've mentioned many times
before it can mean equate to make things
equal
but it doesn't necessarily mean to make
them identical right so equating them
means making them
adequate to each other making them
actually
fit making them commensurate
self-consciousness and Consciousness can
come together and be harmonious you
could say right and that's ultimately
what science is supposed to be
like for Hegel when we're doing actual
Vision shop now there's all sorts of
this in shaft and various Sciences
disciplinary kinds of knowledge and we
can sort of stand back from them and
look at them and be like ah I am the
knower that is the known
yes
except that we are also part of the
known
and we are knowing
ourselves as part of that known so if
the science is about history and human
development philosophy art religion
these are things that can actually be
Sciences for our you know hegel's point
of view right
um you can have a vision Shafter the
logic which is the the next big book
right but you can also have a vision
shaft of geshikto the science of history
and a philosophy and Aesthetics but also
you know if Hegel was around later on of
psychology of Sociology these things
what we often call the human Sciences
those are about us right and Hegel would
say these researchers who think that
somehow they're like the subject and
everything else is the object they're
doing something that's not adequate to
the the scientific nature of their their
work right they've lost sense of that
they're doing something that is in a
certain sense pseudoscientific not
pseudoscientific in the sense that like
astrology is but
um be that as it may uh coming back to
to the text Hegel says
equating self-consciousness with its
Consciousness then he's a spirit that is
in and for itself and
differentiated into its moments is a
knowing that is for itself so being in
and for itself as spirit means being a
knowing for itself what does this mean a
comprehension beguyphen in general that
as such now he brings up another term
substance
substance has not reached
substance within the hegelian dialectic
is nearly always something in its
beginning State something that we study
something that maybe we're interested in
ethically but it doesn't have
subjectivity the way that it ought to as
Spirit does and as science in again it's
full sense possesses for someone like
Hegel so he says a comprehension a
macgython that substance is not reached
why not because substance doesn't grasp
things like that Spirit grasps things
subject grass things the self grass
things science grasps things a
comprehension in general that substance
is not reached substance is not in its
own self
an absolute knowing so does that mean
well oh let's leave substance behind no
no no we need to transform substance and
anything that still Bears The Mark of it
that bears the solidity of it we need to
transform that through the rest of this
section through this whole process
through Spirit knowing itself
into science now coming into time and
into the actual world something
new is emerging
in the process of emerging it's not
emerging right this this point in time
it has been emerging and now it can
recognize itself as emerging in time and
actuality